[Music]
on July 4th 2015 a NASA spacecraft
called New Horizons was 5 billion
kilometres away from Earth it was only
ten days away from Pluto after flying
for nine and a half years when it
suddenly dropped out of contact but
let's back up a little as of 1989
mankind had successfully sent craft to
every known planet in the solar system
except one Pluto you may have heard that
astronomers don't consider Pluto or its
brethren to be planets however most
planetary scientists still do which is
why we're using that terminology here
there's a limited amount we can learn
about Pluto from Earth because it's so
far from us
Pluto however is a scientific goldmine
it's located in a region called the
Kuiper belt home to many small planets
hundreds of thousands of ancient icy
objects and trillions of comets this
mysterious region holds clues to the
formation of our solar system and it was
long tantalizingly beyond our reach
until New Horizons its objectives
explore Pluto collect as much scientific
data as possible transmit it back to
earth then explore farther out in the
Kuiper belt to achieve this the New
Horizons team outfitted their craft with
seven state-of-the-art scientific
instruments those included Ralph a set
of cameras powerful enough to capture
features the size of city blocks in
Manhattan from tens of thousands of
kilometers away and Rex designed to use
radio waves to measure Pluto's
atmospheric pressure and temperature all
of the onboard equipment had to be built
to be both reliable and lightweight
because New Horizons had an additional
challenge it had to reach its target as
fast as possible
why around 2020 Pluto will reach a point
in its orbit where its atmosphere could
freeze and due to the tilt of its axis
more and more of Pluto's surface is
shrouded in darkness every year
Pluto completes a full orbit once every
248 earth years so it would be a long
wait for the next prime opportunity to
visit to see how New Horizons got to
Pluto in time let's jump to its launch
it's three rocket stages accelerated New
Horizons to such great speeds that it
crossed the 400,000 kilometers to the
moon in just nine hours about a year
later the craft reached Jupiter and got
what's called a gravity assist that's
where it flies close enough to the gas
giant to receive a gravitational
slingshot effect
New Horizons was then flying at around
50,000 kilometers per hour as it would
for the next eight years to cross the
remaining Gulf to Pluto going at such an
astonishing speed meant that slowing
down to get into orbit or land would
have been impossible that's why New
Horizons was on a flyby mission where it
would get just one chance to screen by
Pluto and make its observations the
flyby would have to be fully automated
since at that distance any signals to
guide it from earth would take four and
a half hours to reach it so the team
loaded the ship's computer with a series
of thousands of commands called the core
load that would begin to execute when
the craft was six and a half days from
Pluto but when New Horizons was just 10
days out disaster almost struck ground
control lost contact with the spacecraft
after two nerve-racking hours
New Horizons came back online but
Mission Control discovered that its main
computer had rebooted losing the entire
core load and other critical data
without that it would soon whiz by Pluto
with virtually nothing to show for the
mission Alice Bowman the missions
operations manager led a team for 72
sleepless hours to get the instructions
loaded back into New Horizons in time
without room for a single error she
and her team pulled it off and New
Horizons began taking and broadcasting
breathtaking images those observations
have revealed a delightfully varied
world with ground fogs high-altitude
Hayes's possible clouds canyons towering
mountains faults craters polar caps
glaciers apparent dune fields suspected
ice volcanoes evidence for past flowing
liquids and more one of the most
exciting discoveries is the 1000
kilometer wide Sputnik clinician laser
Sputnik plena
is mainly composed of slowly churning of
frozen nitrogen and we've never seen
anything like it in our solar system the
exploration of Pluto was a great success
but New Horizons isn't done yet
On January 1st 2019 it'll break its own
record for farthest explored object when
it visits a Kuiper belt object called 2
0 1 4 mu 6 9 which is orbiting the Sun
another billion kilometers farther away
than Pluto the world is holding its
breath to see what it'll find there the
author of this lesson dr. Alan Stern is
a planetary scientist and the leader of
the New Horizons mission he worked for
over 26 years leading a team of hundreds
to accomplish this incredible act of
exploration for the full story
we highly recommend Alan's book chasing
New Horizons the epic first mission to
Pluto co-authored with planetary
scientist David Grinspoon